playing the eastern lit Serena it's a
two hour long tournament I'm joining
about halfway through first place
currently has 18 points so I might be
able to make a running and I'm gonna do
something a bit differently this this
stream let me fix the layout every
opening in every game is going to be a
gambit so we'll start with Alafia and
gambits which I know almost nothing
about it's a good sign my opponent is
thinking here the only thing I know is
that if takes then I think black can
play e4 and if this okay now we have we
have some kind of reverse Kings gambit
b3 this looks fun actually put the
Bishop on c5
and I actually have the threat of Knight
g4 like if this would be too noisy for
okay so he's playing safely
let's castle is it still a gambit if
your opponent declines it's probably
let's play Queenie eights this is a
benefit of moving the F pawn early as it
opens up the diagonal for the Queen
creates some more attacking
possibilities let's play F for opening
the bishop you had a combination of the
Queen and both bishops looks pretty
terrifying for whites hello people in
the chat
nirvan raymond Kover Guy Debord
I'll start with this AB simile ah it's
South's Jay Brower I'll put the Queen on
each six because maybe I want to sack
exacting looks really fun or maybe
Knight g4 going after f2 this play with
like b3 Bishop b2 a for a little bit
meaningless I'm just giving me free
Tempe there's also the plan of g5g for
so many fun things to consider
we'll see what he does and then I'll
decide what to do don't one is letting
you play the Budapest I just recorded a
third video on the Buda Fest which
should be uploaded within a few hours
yeah Knight g1 trying to be safe let's
play this I mean I can add more
attackers like my knight can come in my
rook can come to the G file at some
point White's King side should be
cracked
yeah g3 I was slightly expecting now I'm
going for I mean I thought three I was
expecting but now I'm focused on getting
the knight to g3
I mean if I want to I could win the rook
like play Bishop f2 in the rook is
trapped but there should be something
better what to do I'll start with Bishop
f2 like White is pretty much paralyzed
here such a fun position 9 f1 so it
takes and then takes on h3 let's just
play Queen h4 such a cluster of pieces
on the Kings side I want to play this in
this like the majority of square is in
this quadrant are occupied by something
ok so I could take with Queen or I take
the pawn take with pawn here I take King
takes takes takes takes and I have the
Queen h2 coming that looks good enough I
mean I really don't want to give away my
dark squared Bishop but it's probably
worth it
as yet queen h2 can't be stopped I think
it's force mates like these pieces just
get in the way
Matt grow sets good to see you're still
around happy new year
okay so this guy's suffering and now
it's made into I could promote okay end
it there life starts her first time in a
long time playing whoa laughs Ian gambit
someone commented on YouTube to make a
video on the LA feein so maybe that will
be my video just that game but anyway
okay let's continue i'll beserk this
game play d4 and every game that i play
will be a gambit
so if my opponent doesn't let me play
again but it's all have to be creative
I'm pretty sure there's gambits to play
against everything unless my opponent
doesn't move whoo-hoo g6 Sarah gambit
against g6
let's play h4 gab at my pawn
not really Gannett I'm just offering a
trade I mean I just want to find a way
to sacrifice something for initiative
and the time is right I can play h6 and
Romita thanks for the sub appreciate
that two months in a row okay so now I
could play h6
there's a funny line h6 Bishop f6 and
then I'm trapping the bishop with e5 and
if Bishop f8
then I kind of wish it was bug house to
play Knight of 6 mates put the bishop on
g5 maybe invade f6 I mean I still have
to again did something but I guess I'll
first develop f6 more than move well if
I just gambit a piece B 5 take stick
sticks let's do it like this I'll play
Bishop c4 I'm gathering a bishop because
I want to win the e6 pawn if he takes I
might even take with Knight first and
then e 6 should just be a goner and
Queen R 3 is coming also I'm threatening
to trap the Queen so this looks pretty
nice play e4 f5 I don't know if I want
to be that self-destructive speaking of
self-destructive this queen is dead but
black is gonna have three minor pieces
for the Queen because he can take and
then okay it should be better for whites
because I have more Center and blacks
not developed
go for this pawn munch d5 d6 because now
I just want to open a at least one file
get the rook into play probably continue
with Knight d5 eventually queen g4
coming
trying to hit him from all directions
King v8 is pretty much forced I think
there's some force mates a king bee a
truck t8 I'd see a queen g3
there's really no way to avoid that
how's the nice finish okay back to
tournament so that was a weird opening
my opponent play the little bit too
passively and usually against each for
black should spend the time to play age
six or h5 suggests you a book for London
with to Bishop f4 I can suggest you a
eight hour video course which I I
compiled for I chess net if you type in
the command London and the chat it
should give you a link to the course if
you want a book I think there's a book
by Sedlak you type in sed Lak London and
you should be able to find it on Amazon
okay so we have a new game if you play
as c4 I was gonna play the Budapest's
Knight c3 let's play c5 Gavin hang upon
if he plays d5 maybe I'll play be fine
yeah weird position and this is gonna be
similar to like a Banco gambit he'll
probably take unless he doesn't take if
he takes maybe Queen a 525 93 94 of the
52
I have an idea I'm gonna play 25
provoking Knight c3 that I'm gonna play
Bishop b7o I mouse slipped
I wanted to play Bishop e7 and attack
the pawn that's not actually a bad mouth
slit my Bishop is decently placed on a6
I'll go for the V and Kev oh yeah this
is very reminiscent of some like bingo
gambit structure oh is this a free pawn
looks like a free fall
I think he forgot the Knights pinned I
could take the knight first now let's
take the knight first
attacking the Queen it takes back I'm
probably going to take on a 6 with the
Queen
just to prevent white from castling if
white wants the castle he'll probably
have to trade Queens no I'll play this I
enjoy the tension here because now I win
another pawn now I'm up upon winning c3
and a tall castle
rook b7 scary can allow it
it's weird I gather the pawn now I'm up
upon and now White has a little bit of
compensation but trades make me happy
let's take I do I want to take yeah
let's take and then play this
fight for the B file I'm happy trading
all the rooks because these D pawns are
weak and the a pawn is also weak and if
he doesn't want to trade rooks and he
concedes the B file hello to more people
in the chat there's too many people to
say hello to I see some recommendations
be savvy YouTube series inspired you to
learn chess that's good to hear
I don't think it's officially a series
but I am hoping to upload regular
content like apart from just the live
streams on d6 or f6 probably d6o then
knight c6 Wow d6 knight c6 it's a tricky
move
so maybe f6
yeah if I loud knight c6 I would have
lost upon I think I can play this just
trying to develop eventually I want to
play like d6 and the knight c7
93 is pretty much first I think and then
I'll bring the king in I had this move
oh but then he had night c4 then Knight
c3 I should have found Knight d5 but
that's okay position is still good still
up a pond I'll put the knight on d4 and
centralize the king
yeah it still takes a bit of work to win
this house White's King is decently
placed I think the plan is to bring the
King to a five that's weird but like his
King can't access any of these squares
so King a five is hard to stop I just
want to win the pawn and this night I
think is relatively restricted the h3 is
a good sign ooh
so he's defending kind of
hmm okay let's start with this just want
to make white tied down there's actually
a funny idea here just to continually
play waiting moves because white White's
tied down and the king can't move so the
only things I can move are these pawns
so I think eventually the pawns are
going to become interlocked and then
white should be and zips long so I guess
the question is how do I just force the
pawns to be interlocked maybe g5 so I
don't want to create too many weaknesses
if you play the g4 I play h6 and white
sands lives long also 92 would be mates
so oh actually if g4 I just take on f3
so White's already ins looks long Wow
if he moves the knight I win the pawn
the King can't move and none of the
pawns can move that's so nice I'm
dedicating this to all the German people
and the chats who invented the words
looks long so he'll probably flag or
lose all his pawns okay or at least
loose one Punk
and now it's a matter of pushing this
past pawn hmm let's bring the king it
would be a bit adventurous bring the
King to be two because then it creates
this nice open lane let's play this I
just want to end the game right away
that's a nice mate yeah pushing the pawn
would have eventually won but yeah this
is the main reason that flanking b2 to
checkmate from behind okay that was nice
let's move on
I'm not taking challenges I'm playing
the Eastern lutes arena trying to play
again bit every single game which I
think I'm achieving the first game was
laughing again but the second game I
gamba did some piece and this game was
some weird like Banco type gambit
I am streaming from Indonesia i refilled
my data so I have enough data left for
the next few days let's play d4 again
I'll bezerk there's a gambit I wanted to
play okay in this case I'm gonna play
the UM what's this called the black
Mardy Murie gambit Knight c3 and then
eventually f3 I know very little about
this I think I know one line for black
against this seems like he kind of knows
what he's doing I don't really know what
I'm doing you just want to focus on
developing okay so I'm officially down
upon well Castle and try and make use of
that file always play king h1 and I
think I'll start by maneuvering the
Queen to the Kings side try and make
some threats put the bishop on that
floor as there's a few pieces that would
like to access a 5 and all my pieces are
relatively happy
every single piece has some purpose I'll
play it for make him sad now what to do
I don't want to trade probably 95 I
don't think black can take with either
piece because I take back and open the D
file and meanwhile I just want to do
this and maybe sack and maybe rip d3
looks nice so he's playing defensively
let's play Bishop d3 the bishops happier
targeting the Knights Queen h4
unexpected I mean bishop g3 looks
sensible let's do it if he takes and I
take on each seven
also f7s attacks twice so he defended
but now Bishop e2 and the Queen doesn't
have any squares to keep f7 defended
that gives me a free queen and now it's
a matter of trading and winning and
attacking pawns I'm enjoying these
gambit so far let's play rook here I
want to remove the knight and win this
fun and Bishop f5 will trade
yeah I'll just keep training I mean I'm
up a full I'm up a queen for a night and
I have enough time free pond
yeah it's nice beating up a queen I'll
take take with the rook and then take
the Knights
it's hard to keep an eye on the chat
some talk about penguins I have seen a
lot of penguins recently the only thing
I have to pay attention to is not
plundering back rank mates yeah I
guarantee rookie eights gonna be played
and then I'll crush all his dreams with
h3
ah there's some funny mating idea which
I would really like to set up which
involves a queen sack but now it's too
difficult so let's take
restrict the king
let's play Bishop e6 threatening made in
one
there we go okay so how many games was
that four four games four wins
forty second place fourteen points do I
know what time I'll be streaming next
this is probably my last stream for a
couple days my next stream will probably
be January 11th or no January 7th rhymes
with 11 I mean they'll play another
gambits what is this I didn't know what
this opening is this already looks a bit
uncomfortable I guess I'll take play
knight c6 maybe it's uncomfortable for
both of us I chief for Bishop g5 oh I
could take on e4 this looks really bad
though might as well take on e4 and hope
for the best
yeah this looks really bad what have I
done
so I'm gambling a knight
oh man d5 maybe
this is so bad what did I do
d6 knowmaybe d5 I just have to keep
initiative maybe have some hope on time
at least this king is stuck in the
center but my king is also stuck in the
center maybe here go for some trade me
g7 so now I want to Castle kingside at
least he's 2200 he's gonna be me Alessi
flags
you have to retreat before coming mmm
good move
also a good move I have to take do I
confuse him let's confuse them this
looks very suspicious but it's a massive
skewer fork don't see this every day but
I'm down to pieces at least maybe he's
confused a little bit
please stay confused if Bishop f4 c6
probably
removing the guard of the bishop if
night c7 rook c8 it's an interesting
move let's move back I have to win back
at least one piece 9 c7 rook c8 AHA but
he's doing stuff maybe rook rook CA 96
good move I have to do it for this line
this is really bad
oh but am i trapping the Knights maybe
I'm trapping the Knights or maybe not or
maybe I am I'm only down the exchange
then it's a miracle he's gonna get
activity no mm BB 5
to get the bishop to have six
okay I'm trying
to activate but I can't get mated
this is really unfortunate okay let's
play here centralize the king
and push that fun
No okay he had some move I'm about to
flag though
so unfortunate I tried I tried really
hard requesting a Danish opening I
assume that's the Danish gambit I could
try the Danish gambit
sure okay I'm 48th place four wins one
loss that was actually a hard-fought
game but I don't think I ever came back
from being down material yeah if I'm why
I'll play e4 next the zurk
hey it's bits Carroll cod are there any
gambits against Carroll Khan
let's find that f3 I'll have to maybe
invent something I'll play the reverse
budapest with Knight g5 if he takes he
doesn't take so how do I gamma the pawn
let's play this
maybe e6 soon he's not letting me
sacrifice material I'll play d4 take the
pawn I want the file to open up before
it's dubious but it has its purposes
because now at least my rook is active
and I have the bishop hair it's actually
not so bad like he just gave away his
dark squared bishop
so all these squares can be in my
control unless he plays c5 please don't
play c5 actually if you play c5 at
Bishop b5 check let's do this
maybe this if c5 I probably play c4 or
maybe Bishop c1
yeah probably a bishop Siwon not the
soundest of play but I'm trying
still theory some some truth in that
statement but not really that's a good
move maybe a bishop here
I wanted to play bishop here earlier but
there was not five earlier but now a
night at five I can just take it and in
the meantime I would like to attack make
g4 g5 not sure what that does f5 let's
play g4 just want to open the G file
I always play Bishop f1 but not in this
position Bishop is happier on d3 okay
let's push pawns
I mean the goal is to open up like one
file on the kingside but it might be
hard to do keep pushing
I'll take with Queen
yes now he's preparing night seeds
it's kind of hard to stop so let's play
off three it's night c8 Bishop III mmm
good move I have to go for this and
maybe I can take if takes t6 I can take
care first and weird stuff is happening
yeah this is annoying legally castle I
can't it's now okay I'm I'll be
temporarily down a night but the point
is after rook takes you six I want to
play Queen d5 and just pin everything
hey it's a sub C nation chess my first
ever subscriber subbing for 14 once in a
row a year in two months
it's a long time Wow
I forgot he can save his night and I'm
low on time let's play this attacking
the pawn ah he's trading Queens No
this is really bad I'm gonna have to
pull some miracle nice I'm winning f4
I'm winning a seven now this is Knights
attack rookie two is a mistake and he
can't set up any mating attack g5 I just
want pissant
maybe rook is gonna play 93 let's defend
the pawn I want to play rook c6 keep
checking the King
somehow the positions actually okay I
think you might have perpetual now he's
playing for one
hey it's a sub I'll thank you later that
was a good move
okay time is becoming a factor
this is nerve-racking
using a flag
hey I want a game from a really bad
position back to tournaments
thanks for the sub craw ftv tree Shay
that's that was a dirty game on multiple
levels forty second place the gambits
will continue last couple positions were
not good from the opening after trying
to fix that maybe play a more sound
gambit
I still will try to play the Danish if
it's possible
okay now I'm playing al Phil oh I'll
Phil oh seven Alexandra botas with a
raid the largest raid ever okay welcome
Alexandra boat has fans and thanks for
the yeah thanks for sharing the viewers
so I'm trying to play gambits every game
but it's hard to play a gambit in this
line I'm gonna play a 3 B 4 it's the
only reasonable way that I see of like
sacking upon but you're gonna take it
Wow cuz now I know I'll keep developing
this actually looks really reasonable
like this at a three I'll play d4 next
d5 coming is a Danish theoretically
sound mmm it's not great against high
level players like black and very easily
equalized but yeah if people want me to
play a particular gambit let me know in
the chat ok so now the threat is Bishop
takes d6 winning back stuff oh this is
so tempting I want to play f4 and just
gambit the rest of the pawns let's do it
Queen takes g2 ripped g1 because open
files are sometimes more valuable than
pawns in this case may be pawns are
still valuable but at least I'm I'm
holding on to my main center pawns
I've gambit at all the wing pawns time
to Castle my king is safe and this Queen
should be trapped at some points like
rook h1 or of g1 let's stop the Queen
from retreating h6 is coming
but then rook b5 what is this
rook b5 b6 d5 looks fun
because now I just want to open the
center like my pieces are all developed
but the center is not open which might
require sacrificing more pawns now there
is bound to be some trade
let's sack the book he takes the rook
this is looking so fun des cailloux 88
thanks for the sub Alexandre botas is
going to shower good night good night
Alexandre it's got to be late in
California huh yeah it's 2 p.m.
2:30 p.m. in Indonesia do I take let's
take wait a minute yeah let's take
there's gonna be some trades but I'm
hoping I'll have enough fuel left
oh it's 11:36 not too late
yeah so we're trading a lot of stuff I
just want to sack one of the rooks like
I might play rook takes g7 maybe this
now I have a rook outpost and I'm
preparing this in this this is such a
weird game
rook c8 interesting Queen d3 is nice
going for Queen g6 increasing pressure
on the D file still want to play 94 okay
so he finally takes it rook let's say
good night or do I take with Queen
or do I play queen g6 check so many
choices
let's take with Knights because this
Knight and rook are completely out of
play and while they might down I'm down
the exchange and two ponds which isn't
bad so I'm basically up a knight and
rook and you six is a main targeted
thing I want to play this
she's only helping me to and I just want
to take next can't really be defended
if King f7 I take twice and then play
Queen h3 in the end and win the rook
all their lies if he doesn't take the
rock I have queen g6 coming that I
should probably calculates queen g6 King
a favor of d6
looks good enough preparing 96
wait 96 ki7
let's start with queen g4 targeting the
rook realizing this might be still a bit
tricky
yeah the Kings kind of escaping let's go
for this
I'm trying to prevent King g8 cuz now if
King G had I taken win the rook
meanwhile thought I had some threaded
like knight c6
maybe just my e6 if Knight f5 trying to
paralyze black black is pretty much
paralyzed right the Queen can't really
move the Knights pinned the plan is
probably a 5 f4 or f6 5 takes yeah
if Queen or if you either piece can take
actually I play Knight g5 just winning
this is like puzzle rush takes here and
then mate next move otherwise I win the
Queen I did not play a knife f5 I forgot
about knife f5 more like knife g5 I'm
playing rook d6 because I want to play
Queen g6 and have some fancy mates
[Music]
what's the best way to win
I'll just do this
humping the other nights or not
okay queen g6 is just too tempting this
box completely stuck and rookie 68 is
unstoppable
that was a really bizarre game like
sacking for pawns and then sacking some
exchange and then that's keeping
compensation I have to try this a three
before move some more times see if it's
actually playable so I'm in 37th place
that game took a while about 17 minutes
left we'll have time for a couple more
games your Asaf gambit well it's hard to
play when I'm black let's play my
favorite opening if white allows it
never mind
what's a gamete I can play against this
let's play over verse Evans gambit this
is probably really dubious didn't even
take the pawn because you pre move
Knight f3 I'll play b4 such a weird
position
I play c6 and keep kicking the knight
mmm let's find out f6 let's take
I mean I attempted to gambit the b-pawn
maybe I'll attempt again did more stuff
but first let's do some normal stuff
first d6 and develop I think a decent
plan is just to go for the immediate g5
g4 takes takes okay this looks fine I
just want to play g4 Wow now white is
that's not actually a sacrifice okay
let's still go for g4 and this is gonna
be confusing this might just be bad for
black I was expecting like takes maybe
you should have taken on g4 now okay
things are simplifying take on h3
somehow material is equal I could win
the pawn
don't really want to take the pawn but
too late
97 so I'm up a pawn but my structure is
really bad
let's play this you might win the pawn
back and we'll have some opposite Clary
Bishop position which actually I'm might
be getting some attack because where is
a king going
I give king h2 it's kind of stuck if
King F want I keep checking play this oh
he just wants to take on e7
that's annoying
let's play five
he's playing very fast I should probably
play faster me rook g6 the one benefit
black has in this position is a passed
pawn okay hear the sound of the
ice-cream truck do ice cream trucks
exist in Indonesia some sound wait I
want to trade both rooks now I'm hungry
to take and I take b1
okay I'm trading both rooks
it's a sad decision but it's life
now I'm hoping to somehow win the
hopsicle fish avenging which probably is
very unlikely but okay these pawns are a
little bit fixed so there's some targets
I'll put the pawn on f4
that's a good move
I'll do this
because I have to take
that's a good move
I have a trick I don't know if it works
but I'm gambling a pawn in the endgame
as if he takes I play a three I think no
idea if this works he's scared to take
okay
so let's play King f7 put the bishop
here insuring the king is tied down
maybe g5
gee for probably no good so let's do
this I have an outside passer if somehow
we traded bishops it would be winning
for black but that's hard to achieve
the goal is to bring the king to be
three or maybe put the pawn on each five
first
actually I'll put the bishop on g6 first
interesting
I don't know who's playing for a win
though
I'll play c5 if you play c5 I'm probably
happy
I'll put the bishop on d1 then
reposition my King on e6 and put my pawn
and c6
the problem is I don't want to allow
king e5
so it's a bit tricky
you'll put the bishop on b1
and then I want to walk around to be
five it's very risky play and now I'm up
on time
this is a plan
okay this is actually feeling slightly
better that was a good move got there we
could trade
but now I'm up on time the trying Fagin
and also just win the position too
somehow I flagged him 92 moves feel
slightly dirty but it was an interesting
endgame like can't let your guard down
the position keeps evolving there's all
these keen maneuvers I was inspired by
Magnus Carlsen because there were many
games in the World Championship Carlson
was just playing out like completely
drawn positions but he was trying to
find ideas so that's the nature of chess
I think I have time for a one more game
we'll try and finish it with the gambits
to keep the theme alive I've not really
been looking at the chat ok I'm playing
b5 because that's some sort of gambit
and then we'll play a6 some very early
sort of Banco gambit efore is not a bad
move can play play this if 'if I've then
I have the d5 square
and this diagonals nice might be hard
for white to develop the bishop so soon
I'm probably threatening to take and
then take back
so at night f3 was probably the best
move I'll go for a Bishop g7 and
castling
have to be careful they can take and
then take care and then Bishop g7
always have to be aware if Bishop takes
f7 sacrifices but I don't think it works
no I just want a castle I have a double
feed in keto and then extra open file
the queenside files are open typical of
the Bangko play h6 question the bishop
it's a sub l cap it and PDX
thanks for the son three months in a row
Oh El Capitan
okay that name was slightly confusing
let's play this move I want to win a
five good move maybe I can do this if he
takes in wins e7 I should win be two in
the end unless you plays Bishop a3 just
possible but then I can at the very list
lease 25 I forgot about d7 I guess I'll
have to treat this as AG andit now even
more of a gambit
rook t8 probably yeah I gave away the
pawn for the open file
but is it enough compensation
I just want to play Bishop c8 attacking
the Queen and the bishop and then
there's Queen c4 I guess it's a kind of
forcing Bishop CA Queen c4 Knight a5 I
can't draw I was not a 5 Queen B 4
[Music]
ninety-seven do anything 97 just looks
sad Roque 5 there's a 4
they should see a queen see 495 queen
bee for don't really see much
g5 and g5 is only helping him
maybe rook d5 let's play rook t5
targeting the pawn he can still win the
e7 pawn but I don't think he wants to
take on c6 Bishop c4 I probably take
with the Knights on e5 AHA but then he
wins g6 and takes takes takes takes
takes takes that's unfortunate
that's not good if I take with rook this
is really not good
maybe Bishop c8 let's try it what else
to do
although she my queen I have very big
problems here because the brook has pins
of the pond which is pins of the king
and g6 is gonna fall again I'm probably
gonna be hoping for some miracle well
okay if Queen g3 out of rook c5 green
out for now a seven so a problem maybe
g5 Bishop takes takes takes that's not
good
so let's play this I'm sacking the
exchange gambling more material and at
least okay when he wins the rook I'll be
attacking b2 and I'll have threats of g5
so still some initiative
he's hesitating which is a good sign
be three Wow so if I take it's a good
move because he's making me think I
think I'll go for this trying weather
the storm maybe I can take
can I take only five maybe I'll play
this move
such a sad move but at least I'm
defending stuff
listen this
and I have plans of rook 85 or C 6 may
be attacking e5
I'm currently up my Appa piece I'm up a
bishop for three pawns now I have two
pieces for rook and three pawns right
place e6
I go away with this
no because Queen takes f7 so let's play
this this is unpleasant let's play this
attacking 'if I've approached g3 I take
good move
yeah this is really sad I still have my
minor pieces though Queen takes me five
is coming or rook takes e5
yeah somehow this still looks okay maybe
rook takes a too soon or would that be
too soon
a queen a six solid-looking move o queen
of sixes of wonder no such a bad move
oh but he didn't see it he buggers his
queen it's a miracle he could have just
taken the Queen and then won the night
what a terrible move okay so now let's
not blunder this away keep my composure
put the Bishop on e5 work the rooks
take a look go for meats
let's play Bishop e5
there we go okay I was not expecting to
win that game at a certain point like it
seemed like every move he was just
punching me in the face the the probably
the computer graph of this game is gonna
be like a roller coaster but roller
coasters are fun okay that was a fun
stream a lot of messy
gambit games it's hard to play again at
every game but I think I'm going to end
it there because this was very stressful
thanks guys for watching and thanks for
the donation Dave g-dragon
yeah I do have to go so I'll be back in
the future stay tuned for a video on
YouTube tonight and I'll see you guys
soon bye